back get back in dick how do I do
that's hard no how long do you think it
would take me to be a backup dancer for
I don't know have had that's Jack well
night he's a dancer and choreographer
he's also the creative mind behind many
of Beyonce's iconic performances I
caught up with Jack well at the
monster's dance convention in New Jersey
he was teaching choreography to
literally hundreds of kids I quickly got
a sense of the talent and work ethic
that made him successful
the story goes that you were teaching
Beyonce choreography at age 18 yeah how
did you get to meet Beyonce had that
whole thing started so I moved to LA
right out of high school and literally
maybe a year into LA I was that just
auditioned for Michelle Williams with
Frank Gatson he enjoyed me my freestyle
it was like hey I got this Beyonce
record can you come in New York tonight
when you get here she likes you you'll
stay if not we'll get you back on a
plane in LA what was your reaction I
mean yeah jaquail went on to choreograph
stars like JLo Britney Spears Christina
Aguilera and more Oh is your favorites
worthless that all very special do you
know that's like a parent saying all
their kids are special because these are
all stars
most recently jaquail collaborated with
Beyonce for her famous Beach Ella
performance the choreography
incorporated homecoming
it's made popular by historically black
colleges and universities it was a smash
hit after the convention jebel agreed to
give me a personal dance lesson just
watch for yourself I want to know how to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sweethearts work maybe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay it's painfully obvious that
I'm not gonna be dancing like Beyonce
anytime soon but I did have one more
question for Jack well will you say hi
to be on safer
[Music]
[Music]